AND SECOND IN THE LEAGUE WITH
MATT THREE IN HIS LAST FIVE
GAMES AFTER NOT GETTING A P P
>> Sam: VLASIC.
A LOT OF MONEY TIED UP IN  BACK.
KAY OTHERS.TIME.
>> Sam: SHARKS ABLE TO CLEAR IT
TO NINTH IN THE
OPEN BAND.
STROME WITH A BIG DRIVE, HE
HE HAD TO REACH TO KEEP IT
GOING.
ONE MORE POWER PLAY BECOMING
MORE CONSISTENY HILL.O MUCH.
>> Joe: HE JUST READS THE PLAY
SO
RANGERS WITH A 1-0 LEAD.
>> Joe:
GAUTHIER. THE NETTING.
PLAY TROUBA.
TROUBA CONTROLS.
THEY WILL MOVE IT OUT.
>> Sam: GOODRDR IT AROUND THE
BOARDS. ON THE ACTION NOW WITH
FAN
FANDUEL.
STOPPED BY UP PLAY
ZONE, GETTING ASSISTS.
HERE HE IS.
HE'LL LOOK ODAY,
SO RYMER LEADING TEAM
SCORER, TIMO MEIER.
YOU SEEE MIDWAY POINT, SECOND P
GAME HAS REALLY BEEN GOOD ON
HERE, GUESS WHAT?
NOBODY SEES HIM. NET.
BOLINO PLAYS IT BACK.SOON.
NOW TIMO
SHESTERKIN DEPARARMETH FOR LAFR.
OUT IT GOES.
DEFENSEMAN GETS CAUGHT.
CHIETL
>> Joe: THE TO TOMAS HERTL.T, T.
GETS TRIPPED DOWN BY
YOU'LL SEE COUTURE IN THE MIDDLE
RUDOLFS BALCERS GAVE IT AWAY TOE